doesn't that warrant naming a second
Special Counsel as 20 members of this
committee wrote you three-and-a-half
months ago asking you to do well mr.
Comey is no longer the director the FBI
thank goodness we have an excellent man
of integrity and ability and chris ray
and i think he's going to do an
outstanding job and i'm very happy I
would say not asking for time the
gentleman I would say looks like is not
enough basis to appoint a special
counsel all right that was freedom
caucus member Ohio Congressman Jim
Jordan today grilling the Attorney
General Jeff Sessions on why the Justice
Department has not appointed a special
counsel to investigate the scandals I
just outlined the poor youth surrounding
Hillary Clinton congressman Jordan is
here along with Florida congressman Matt
gates and Ron de Santos thank you all
for being there all right Jim let me let
me start with you yeah a week ago Friday
my sources multiple sources told me a he
did not recuse himself from uranium 1b I
have sources telling me that there is
and has been an ongoing investigation do
you believe that to be true well we hope
the second part is true but the the
first part whether he's recuse himself
from uranium one issue or not
you gave contradictory answers to my
colleague mr. gates under his
questioning today so we'll see the key
is that but in fairness is it something
he would be able to tell us it would not
correct
well one hand he said he was not recused
from that on the other hand he said well
maybe I'd have to check to see if I'm
supposed to be recused from that so
again mr. gates made that asked him
those questions and within that same
five minutes he said two different
things
Matt congressman sorry yeah I mean Jim's
absolutely right we had a lack of
clarity from the Attorney General and
just like you're frustrated Shawn were
frustrated we've been calling for three
and a half months for an investigation
into these scandals because if we allow
them to continue we rode the rule of law
the Attorney General at one point said
that he would have the power to appoint
a special counsel and then later he said
he wasn't sure and that may be subject
to a recusal so we left today without a
straight answer on whether or not there
would be a special counsel or even what
the
timeframe would be that's frustrating
let me go to the substance congressman
to Santa's about all of this
I won't regurgitate it took me 20
minutes to lay this all out tonight
there's so much detail but to me the
evidence is so overwhelming
the idea that we've spent a year and
there's no evidence of Trump Russia
collusion Dianne Feinstein said it a
week ago on Chris Wallace's show and
here we are a year later
Noah smoke smoke smoke no fire fire fire
the evidence here is overwhelming fusion
GPS uranium one the email server scandal
call me should be investigated your
thoughts well you're right John I mean
let's just take Trump Russia collusion
not only is there not evidence of
collusion but we know that we think that
the dossier that was used to justify
some of this size was was done through
the Democratic Party paying Christopher
Steele and obviously he had to pay some
of these Russians to be able to get some
of this information we need to know and
jeff sessions would not answer whether
the FBI paid Christopher Steele for that
how much did they pay them and whether
they used it for the right to know
doesn't the American taxpayer to have a
right to know if they paid this guy that
paid Russians for salacious lies about
Donald Trump to influence the election
and the American people to propagandize
lie misinformation to story don't we
have a right to know I think we do it
late and sure that would be the this is
the Tamara context payer we need to know
what the FBI spending money on and if
you look at it if in fact this was
democrat party funded you have the FBI
working with one political party against
another and oh by the way in collusion
with russians who are providing this
information congressman jordan it's the
very thing they said that Donald Trump
did and they have no evidence it won't
be the first time the left accuse us of
what they're actually doing look we
don't know if this happened for sure but
everything points that way and Ron's
exactly right if one major party is
working with financing and working with
the FBI to go after the other major
party taking a national enquirer type
document turning it into an intelligence
document
to spy on Americans associated with
president Trump's campaign that is as
wrong as it gets and again if that
doesn't warrant investigation if that
doesn't warrant a special counsel to
look into it I do not know what does to
me the congressman gates it is this
serious are we going to have an America
today
a dual justice system are we going to
have equal justice under the law because
if I deleted 33,000 emails that were
subpoenaed by Congress if I use bleach
but if I destroyed devices with a hammer
if if I say it how does the FBI director
mother at the time know Russian agents
of Putin are trying to corner the
uranium market we have to import uranium
we don't have enough nine people sign
off on this thing then they got the
transfer of money with people involved
back to the Clintons and then they
funded a phony dossier full of Russian
lies to hijack an election and now we
know she already hijacked a primary the
poor Bernie Sanders he got ripped off it
was rigged from day one Sean you're
absolutely right and this is what makes
the American people sick this notion
that there is one set of rules for the
Clintons and another set of rules for
everybody else it just doesn't happen
we look at this investigation you've got
the very people who may have been
involved in keeping information from
Congress keeping information from
fascinating process but they're in the
process of investigating the President
of the United States they're undermining
our democracy now when they very well
may be witnesses to the actual collusion
with one of the participants of the 2016
election Hillary Clinton this better
happened last word congressman to Santos
well I think everything you laid out
John
uranium one we are working hard in the
Congress we're bringing the informant in
we're gonna get his documents we're
going full-bore on that we will get the
stuff for fusion GPS they're gonna have
to turn that over and then finally Comey
and his memos and how he exonerated
Hillary we're getting all of that
information and we can't let up all
right guys thank you we're not letting
up all right when we